- [Interviewer] So, Jesse. - [Jesse] Yeah?
- [Interviewer] Where are you from?
- [Jesse] DC area.
- [Interviewer] DC?
- [Jesse] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Washington, DC?
- [Jesse] Washington, DC area, Maryland.
- [Interviewer] Maryland?
And how long have you been out here?
- [Jesse] Since 2014.
- [Interviewer] What
brought you out to LA?
- [Jesse] I got out of prison.
- [Interviewer] What
were you in prison for?
- [Jesse] Indecent exposure.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- [Interviewer] Indecent exposure?
- [Jesse] Yup.
- [Interviewer] So, what were the details?
What were you doing?
- [Jesse] It was a load of bullshit.
I was in my own house
and somebody saw me through the window
and I got caged for it.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
Is that the only time
you've been in prison?
- [Jesse] I went in twice for it.
- [Interviewer] What was the other for?
- [Jesse] The same.
- [Interviewer] So you've been in prison
for indecent exposure several times now?
- Yup.
- [Interviewer] And what have you done
since you've been in LA?
- [Jesse] Have a angelic battle
with tanks versus angels.
- [Interviewer] Say that again, please?
- [Jesse] I'm talking to Michael, like-
- [Interviewer] Can I ask
you to speak a little louder?
- [Jesse] I said, archangel Michael,
I've been angelic battling
against angels and demons.
- [Interviewer] Hmm.
- [Jesse] Yup.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
you said you were working
in the porn industry as well for a while?
- [Jesse] I did, I did for a while,
I did, uh, I was Jesse James, porno star,
just heterosexual porn.
I did it for, uh,
I never got paid for it,
they were supposed to pay me but they, uh,
went to jail for some
weed and then they didn't,
I lost the number while I was in jail,
and couldn't contact them again.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
- [Jesse] I barely remember my childhood.
- [Interviewer] You don't remember it?
- [Jesse] Yeah, it was pretty bad.
My mom was real mean. My
dad was all right, though.
- [Interviewer] When you
say your mom was mean,
what does that mean?
- [Jesse] She used to beat me.
- [Interviewer] Hmm. Do you have siblings?
- [Jesse] Uh, no, no. Not really.
- [Interviewer] And no family?
- [Jesse] No.
- [Interviewer] No kids?
- [Jesse] No, I play guitar.
I play guitar, I play hair metal,
and I do hard rock, hair
metal. I was singing.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- [Jesse] I was singing.
- [Interviewer] You were singing?
- [Jesse] Yup. I sing the Scorpions. Yup.
- [Interviewer] Great.
There are a lot of drugs
here on the street,
are you on any of those?
- [Jesse] No, I don't do drugs.
- [Interviewer] You stay
away from the drugs?
- [Jesse] Yup.
- [Interviewer] And where do you sleep,
right here on the street?
- [Jesse] No, in the shelter.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you're in the shelter?
- [Jesse] Yup.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- [Jesse] I read the bible a lot.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- [Interviewer] You read the bible a lot?
- [Jesse] Yeah.
(reads from bible)
- [Interviewer] What's your
favorite part of the bible?
- [Jesse] The Psalms. The Psalms are good.
I pray the Psalms. That's
where all the power comes from.
Comes from the power of the Holy Ghost.
I like the evangelizing and
stuff about the Holy Ghost
and everything like that,
taught me about God.
It's all I could really do,
read the bible out there
to everybody in public.
It is what you're
supposed to do in public,
you're supposed to tell
people about the word of god.
So that's something I do. He
helps me out with everything.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about some of your tattoos,
you have some interesting tattoos.
- [Jesse] Yes, this is the
seal of God right here,
from the book of revelations.
This is the star of David,
the cross, the sign of Jesus Christ
like you find on the back of cars.
- [Interviewer] Yup, and I see
you have "girls girls girls"
under your right eye.
- [Jesse] Girls, girls, girls.
- [Interviewer] Not everybody
has a girls, girls, girls,
tattoo on their face.
- [Jesse] Yeah, I like them as well.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about the -
- [Jesse] This skull one
is about rock and roll,
man, it's about rock and roll right here.
And there's an anarchy,
and this dollar sign.
- [Interviewer] And on
your chest and back,
you have what you call
the largest scorpion
tattoo in the world
- [Jesse] No in Oklahoma,
in Oklahoma that I had
it tattooed in prison.
It's a Scorpio, I'm a Scorpio,
I born October 30th 1979,
the day of the dead, red
horsemen of the apocalypse.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's
quite a tattoo you got.
- [Jesse] That's about
all my tattoos though.
- [Interviewer] That's cool. Jesse,
thank you for talking to
me. Make sure it's good.
- [Jesse] Thank you very much.
- [Interviewer] I appreciate it.